A portion of this video
was sponsored by Walgreens.
Exposure has
far exceeded dangerous levels. If they keep this
up, there's going to be nothing holding him back.
Oh, no, it's too late. Run. Run!
Goodbye, Internet.
Ahem, sorry about AntiPat over there he just
escaped from his containment cell. Pay him
no mind. He's kind of a minor glitch in the
system. Pretty darn harmless, honestly. The
scariest thing about him is just how cringe he is.
Anyway, let's ah. Let's try that again, shall we?
Hello, Internet. Welcome to Film Theory,
the show that just wants to ask, have
you ever experienced a terrible occurrence
that has impacted you significantly? Now,
if you're a fan of our sister location gAmE tHeOrY
or spent any time in the gaming zone of YouTube,
you're probably familiar with Sean
McLoughlin, aka JackSepticeye.
Top of the mornin’ to ya laddies
Across ten years on YouTube. He's proven
himself time and time again as a gamer, as
an entrepreneur, as a philanthropist. But recently
he's also been proving himself as a storyteller.
Don't get me wrong, Sean has never been shy about
hopping into character for one of his videos.
But now it appears as though Sean has something
greater planned for those characters. A wider
connected universe that brings them
all together to tell a story of love,
loss and chaos. And it all begins with one.
The powerful and terrifying AntiSepticEye
Recently, Sean released what has got to be
one of his most ambitious projects
to date The I.R.I.S. PROJECT,
an interactive livestream where the chat used
text commands to cooperatively play a legitimate
video game, solving puzzles and ultimately
unlocking all sorts of new channel LORE.
The video itself follows one specific Sean
character: Chase Brody. Now to catch you
up in case you don't watch every single one
of JackSeptEye’s let's plays Chase is your
typical bro. So much so that a spinoff
YouTube series is called Bro Average.
But while onscreen Chase is living
large with teabagging trick shots.
Offscreen he appears to be having
difficulty with his family life.
This escalates, and ultimately it comes
to a climax at the very end of a 2018
video titled What Do You Want from Me? In
which Chase hears his family screaming.
He goes to explore his house, only to be
confronted by another of Sean's characters,
the unpredictable and violent AntiSepticEye.
It appears that whatever happened here
ended in tragedy because a year later
we get the video simply titled Chase.
In it we watch as Chase approaches a
makeshift grave and then places a photo
of his family on it. They're dead. But
who's responsible? AntiSepticEye? Chase
himself? or something else? He begins to
drink his troubles away until he’s suddenly
teleported to the top of a parking garage.
And it's here in an upload coming three years
later that The I.R.I.S. PROJECT begins in earnest,
continuing the story of Chase, AntiSepticEye and
presumably the rest of Sean's personas. Right now,
that narrative is still in its early stages,
but it's clear that Sean has big plans for
it moving forward. I would assume the next
installment is going to be coming sometime
either next summer or Halloween, based
on how he's been treating these sorts
of uploads in the past. But here's the
thing you don't need to wait that long,
my friends. I think that we've cracked open
what the wider story is. In their pursuit
of discovery and technological growth. The
I.R.I.S. Corporation has gotten too ambitious.
It's attempted to tap into forces that are
far beyond their control. And by doing this,
they've unleashed a force that
threatens not just I.R.I.S. not
just Chase and the other personas,
but all of humanity. So grab your
clipboards and start scribbling away
loyal theorists, It's time to dive in.
Because the main part of this was a live event
that's now unlisted. Let me just start with
a quick recap of what actually happened in The
I.R.I.S. Project that we're all on the same page.
The videos from the live stream
that the chat unlocked are framed
as archival footage of a series of
interviews between Chase Brody and
an unnamed I.R.I.S. scientist. I'm just
going to call this random scientist a name
that comes to the top of my head. Let's
just say Arin. No real reason for that.
Anyway at first, the interview is more of an
interrogation. Arin seems distant and cold.
Shots framed so we don't even see his face. He
refers to Chase as a subject rather than a person.
Arin's questions also seem borderline
nonsensical at first. Does Chase recall
how he was teleported? Has he seen or
heard things that weren't actually there?
seen objects appearing or disappearing?
lost track of time? That sort of thing.
However, as the days of the interrogation
go on and Arin attempts to warm up to chase,
we begin to see his face. And his
questions start getting more personal.
Also, it becomes clear that Chase isn't alone
in the facility. There's something else here,
too. Something that wants to
talk. Something named Echo.
Multiple times throughout the week, other
unseen entities enter Chase's cell. These
beings are what Iris classifies as alters. And
they speak to Chase using what the camera picks.
Up as some sort of strange whisper or whale noise.
We can tell that at least one
of them is tormenting Chase.
And the other is telling Chase that he's special.
Eventually, after the chat unlocked all but one
of the clips in The I.R.I.S. Project livestream.
The facility changed. The power started flickering
on and off. Chairs were strewn about. Red warning
lights blared throughout the building. The
facility is in lockdown. Security guards enter
Chase's room and escort him out as Chase warns
them of the impending danger that they all face.
I.R.I.S. ignores Chase's warnings,
only to discover AntiSepticEye here to
once again wreak havoc on Chase's life.
So now that you're all caught up,
the way I see it, there are three
main mysteries presented to us here.
What's I.R.I.S. up to? How to Chase and
Anti play into all of it? And finally,
who or what is Echo? Well, I believe
we have answers to all three of those
questions today. But before we
start decoding what it all means,
let's take a moment to talk about our
sponsor for this portion of the video.
Walgreens. That's right. The drugstore
store that's literally everywhere noticed
little old us online and sponsored
this episode. We are legit guys.
This holiday season. If you're
looking to keep yourself safe,
you don't need to be locked up and isolated
in a dark, high security research facility.
Instead, you just make sure that you're up to date
with your vaccinations. And thanks to Walgreens,
it is easier than ever to do that.
Most people think that you have to
make a doctor's appointment, wait in line,
the whole thing just to get some vaccines.
But you can actually have one
of Walgreens specially trained
pharmacy experts do it for you super
fast. No special trips to the doctor
you can book online or you can just go in
literally the same day. You can even save
yourself a trip and schedule your COVID
19 and flu vaccines for the same time.
Steph and I both take vaccinations seriously. We
have a child who needs us to stay healthy. We do a
lot of travel to see you guys and speak at events.
We do our best to spend time with family at the
holidays and all of those things mean that we
need to stay as responsible as we can in order to
keep ourselves safe. Case in point, just a
few weeks ago, our entire team came out to
North Carolina to work together in the same
room for the first time since COVID. There
was a lot of hugging, a lot of jumping
up and down and then a lot more hugging.
Honestly, for a bunch of introverts,
Team Theorist is shockingly close.
But you know what made all of those
close hugs possible scientifically
tested vaccines and Walgreens makes it
easy to access those vaccines quickly,
reliably and professionally. So go
get your vaccinations now, my friends.
That way, by the time you hit the relatives
house, gift swaps, or uncomfortable corporate
mandated holiday parties. You're confident in your
health and your safety. Schedule an appointment
online today at Walgreens.com/schedulevaccine.
Again, that's Walgreens.com/schedulevaccine
Or you know, you can just click the link
in the description if you don't want to
type all of that stuff out. be smart and
safe this holiday season loyal theorists.
Once again, thank you to Walgreens for
sponsoring that portion of the video.
Let's just jump back into the mystery of I.R.I.S.
to decode what all of it means. Starting with the
last question first, who is Echo? Out of
all the entities that interact with Chase,
this character seems to be the most benevolent.
It wants to help.
When Echo first appears, the I.R.I.S.
camera encounters some interference,
and you can even see the silhouette of some
sort of figure in there. Easy money would
say that that is Echo. But something else you
might not notice here is that all throughout
the rest of the interaction, the camera feed is
glitchy with Chase jumping around a fair bit.
Now, this could certainly be a way to hide cuts
to different takes, but it could also be a hint
as to the identity of Echo. In the live stream,
one of the rooms that we see appears to be some
sort of I.R.I.S. employee break room, and
one of the posters on the wall reads, quote:
“Did you know… altar 5914 is a time
thief! Don't be like altar 5914!”
So since we're seeing some jumps and
Chases conversation here with Echo,
maybe Echo is alter 5914 an entity who is somehow
able to manipulate time. And the glitches we're
seeing aren't actually glitches, but rather
time that's literally being stolen by Echo.
Additionally, if we look at the I.R.I.S.
Twitter feed, we can see that some form of time
manipulation does exist inside this universe.
According to this post about the Retrowave:
a microwave that rewinds old meals
back in time to when they were fresh,
I.R.I.S. started experimenting with time
manipulation technology in the 40’s.
So we know that it is possible within
this universe. That alone would be an
interesting factoid. But that's not all we
hear about time travel in the series. One
other post from the I.R.I.S.Twitter got
my theorist senses working, quote again:
“If you were able to travel back in time and
talk to yourself, what would you tell them?”
What if Echo is Chase from the future somehow
traveling back in time to communicate and
tell Chase that he's special, that he
has a big role to play in this story,
and that it can help because
again, it's him from the future.
It would be quite literally an echo of
events yet to come. Now, admittedly,
that sounds like a big shot in the dark,
but it would help a lot of things in the
series make more sense. For example,
despite I.R.I.S. assuring Chase that
he's never been in the facility before,
he insists that he somehow remembers it.
Sean also explained in his post
stream breakdown that deja vu is
a scientific thing within this
universe. It means something.
What if the deja vu is Chase picking up
bits of his own memories? Memories that
he hasn't made yet, because they're
Echo's memories. That would explain
why I.R.I.S. seems so interested
in his feelings on the subject.
And time travel may not be the only dimensional
technology that I.R.I.S. is messing with here.
I believe that a multiverse of some sort also
exists in this world. In another Twitter post,
I.R.I.S. asks, quote: “People always say
reach for the stars because they think
it's impossible to do so. What if we reached
even further?” The only thing I can think
of that's further than the stars in outer
space are places outside of our universe,
in other universes that might seem
outlandish, but teleporting is established
as a fairly regular occurrence among these
characters. We've already talked about how
Chase teleported to the top of
a parking garage at the end of
one of his videos. But he's far from
the only person to experience this.
First of all, Doctor Scneeplestein, Sean's wacky
doctor character, witnesses an interdimensional
portal through one of his computer monitors
at the end of a 2019 video. That same portal
is seen alongside the magician character Marvin
The Magnificent. In a vision from a 2020 upload.
It's worth noting that both AntiSepticEye
and Chase are also seen in that vision,
showing that all of these characters are
indeed connected in some way. In fact,
AntiSepticEye himself has already directly
interacted with both Dr. Scneeplestein,
as well as another character in the roster,
the silent film performer Jamison Jackson.
What if all of these characters are literally the
same character? just from different universes,
different timelines? And what's more, I.R.I.S.
clearly has an interest in these alter egos,
with several of them likely already
in containment within the facility.
During the original live stream, we
were able to see Jamison's Bow Tie,
Mervyn's mask and several Jacky Boy Man comics
hidden throughout the facility. Were these just
Easter eggs to Sean's other characters? Or could
these characters actually be kept in the facility?
My hunch is that they're here
for a reason. And if I.R.I.S.
has an interest in all of these other
egos, then of course they'd want to
capture AntiSepticEye too. Gotta be a
completionist of the dex and all that.
But why? Why would I.R.I.S. be
so interested in collecting all
these random characters from across
time and space? According to Arin,
I.R.I.S. is a benevolent organization
that's just trying to protect people.
But this, frankly, does not align
with everything else that we see
with I.R.I.S. in the series. First
of all, their treatment of Chase is
borderline torture to the point that they
even make it difficult for him to sleep.
And despite already knowing the answers to
the questions that they're asking of chase,
they decided to push him to the edge in a way
that triggers horrible, repressed memories.
Notice the flashing images that appear here?
graves, bodies, a wedding rings, It’s Chase's
family, the ones that died most likely at
the hands of AntiSepticEye. And the more they
question chase, the more they poke and prod at
his tragic past, the closer AntiSepticEye becomes.
I.R.I.S. knows this and chooses to proceed anyway.
They want AntiSepticEye to show up.
They want him here. But why? What
could they possibly have to gain
from this super dangerous being?
It can't be for the good of the universe,
can it? to contain him? No loyal theorists.
They're doing it to harness the
power that AntiSepticEye holds.
Despite the series taking place
basically in the present day days
I.R.I.S. has access to technology that's
far beyond what we have in our universe. On
their social media page, they talk about
true high definition TV in the 1970s,
implants that make it smarter, microwaves
that can reverse time on specific objects
and quantum displaces that can
change the mass of objects. However,
the piece of tech that we get the most elaborate
explanation for is their watcher security system.
These security cameras have incredibly high 12
K resolution. They can detect both the physical,
health and emotional state of the people they
record. And most importantly to our purposes
today, their wireless and battery-les
thanks to an antimatter power source.
Yeah, I.R.I.S. apparently has antimatter
technology in the year 2019. For proof,
look no further than that Marvin The Magnificent
video that I mentioned earlier. In it,
we get a close up of a spell book. And what's
that written inside? I.R.I.S. equals antimatter.
This is from a video that was uploaded back in
2020. So Sean's been laying the groundwork for
years now. To my knowledge, this is also the
first time that I.R.I.S. was officially used
in the context of this ongoing character
narrative. Though if I'm wrong on that,
feel free to call me out in the comments.
But now we fast forward ahead to the
more recent I.R.I.S. Project upload,
in particular one shot of the Iris
facility from the original livestream.
In it, we see what appears to be a pair of giant
sci-fi power generators. I wouldn't be surprised
if these puppies were running on antimatter
and suddenly with all of this information,
everything starts to make sense. During
the livestream, we saw a room that seemed
to be designed to contain a powerful
humanoid, someone like AntiSepticEye.
And while it's certainly a bit on the nose. The
fact that the people clearly trying to summon
AntiSepticEye have themselves super futuristic
technology that's powered by antimatter.
Coincidence? I think not. I.R.I.S. is trying to
capture Anti and then use him as a power source.
And so they're triggering Chase, poking a sleeping
dragon to get AntiSepticEye’s attention. And,
well, that didn't turn out well for
him. It's interesting. This entire
project plays with the idea of how toxic
social media can be. How people who have
no real stake in something, want to
get involved with the personal lives
of people that they don't even know. Sean
explained as much during his live stream.
In this way, the viewer is playing
the game on the I.R.I.S. livestream,
and the I.R.I.S. Corporation within
the story are representative of people
attempting to insert themselves into
businesses that aren't really theirs.
They're pressing people's buttons.
They're poking and prodding, all in
hopes of getting a reaction. And things don't
end up going well for them. Again, as Sean says,
In universe, I.R.I.S. seems to be doing this
for selfish reasons to capture AntiSepticEye,
to use him as a power source for their
futuristic technology. And we as an
audience are also doing it selfishly
to get to the next part of the story,
to learn more about the people we follow in
line to the point where we probably shouldn't.
Regardless of whether I'm right or wrong about the
story Sean's trying to tell here and the lore of
the World that he's building. I just want to take
a step back and congratulate him on creating a
universe that's so ambitious and one that's so far
outside of his normal content, including going so
far as to make one of the coolest interactive
live events I've ever seen happen on YouTube.
For real, A clap and a half to Sean
and all the developers at Hyper RPG
for putting that one together. You know
that I'm a big fan of content creators
trying new things on their channels and
pushing the limits of their creativity.
So you can bet I'm excited to see where this
one is going to be headed next. So as always,
my friends, in the meantime, remember
It’s a fact. A FILM FACT! Aaaand glue.
Did you really just say “and glue”? As in, you
were just looking for the opposite of “and cut”?
Yeah.
Now,
see this? This right here is why we can't have
any good lore for the channels. All right? Sorry.